Before we discuss the widely
used public key algorithms,
RSA and Diffie–Hellman,
let's go over the background first.
Both RSA and Diffie–Hellman
are based on number theory.
An ancient and yet
active field in mathematics.
These public key algorithms use
modular arithmetic, including
modular edition, modular multiplication
and modular exponentiation.
And they make use of
results from number theory.
Let's briefly introduce
the background of modular arithmetic.
First, let's explain modular addition.
Given a modular M, x plus y,
Mod m is the remainder of
x plus y divided by M.
For example, 2 plus 8 divided
by 10 the remainder is 0.
So therefore 2 plus 8
MOD 10 is 0 whereas,
3 plus 8 MOD 10 is 1,
because 3 plus 8 is 11.
And 11 divided by 10, the remainder
is 1 therefore, 3 plus 8 MOD 10 is 1.
The modular addition if we add a number
and its inverse, then the result is 0.
For example,
If the modulus is 10 then for
k equal to 2 is inverse is 8
because 2 plus 8 MOD 10 is 0.
Having additive inverse means that
modular addition is reversible.
That is, by adding the inverse we can
reverse the result of modular addition.
This is very convenient for
encryption and decryption because, as we
have discussed, we want the encryption
process to be reversible, meaning that
ideally, the decryption process is just
the reverse of the encryption process.
For example, given plain text,
p = 3 Suppose the key k is 2,
and the way we include the plain
text p is to add the key
under modular addition to plain text
p and the result is cipher text c.
So the c equal to p plus k,
which is 3 plus 2 MOD 10.
The result is 5.
There is the cipher text c of
plain text p equal to 3 is 5.
Now how do we decrypt?
To decrypt we use the same process but
instead of using the key
we use the key's inverse.
We know that the inverse of 2 is 8.
So therefore c plus k inverse is 5
plus 8 MOD 10 that is, 13 MOD 10.
The result is 3,
which is exactly the plain text.
And so this is how we can do decryption
by using the exact same process as
the encryption, and instead of using the
key, we use its inverse in decryption.
And we take advantage the fact
that under modular addition,
each number has a inverse.
Therefore each key has a inverse and
we just use the inverse
of the key in decryption.